well a wonderful Monday morning
everybody
we're really excited to be here
Brennan's rubbing his eyes and well
that's because he's got pink eyes so
congratulations buddy you want a success
this is what happens you get an
infection in your eyes is it awful you
did normal other than both eyes it is
apparently it's very contagious it goes
to creating can do that Syria is not
like you know let's just stay in the
left eye now they're like let's go over
to the other eye how does it jump over
to the other eye I get it just [ __ ] you
look it's like like why when you're in
one area and there's a little hill and
you want to see what's on the other side
of that hill they're like let's go over
there
pioneers I know exactly when it happened
when hashtag no race if I tell the story
tune I was in Toronto on it on an
elevator okay
packed elevator with a large large cream
in front of me okay I know creams not
because chin has educated me yeah done
some traveling together yeah you can
tell large screen dude taller than me
mouth about eye level
now I baked I love what's a big curry
about 66 that's a giant crane yeah big
boy big big block lot of milk drinkers
in Korea in a suit with his family again
it's a packed elevating Toronto and he
goes we're talking issues I'll never
forget oh I don't like this billet uh-oh
oh my god he'll scar I'm so silent no no
way
I swear it and I went well you could
feel in your eyelid that's not good
dizzy thing of it couple days later I
started ah I thought of him you son of a
[ __ ] yep you your eyes are basically
holes like they're considered to be
you've got a mouth you got two nostrils
in your eyes and your ears your face is
full of holes my hit but I mean and your
eyes are actually holes yeah you got an
eyeball in it yeah but [ __ ] gets in
there like fluids will stick to your
eyeballs then you're right then you
blink and your eyeball rolls back in
that fluid gets right in the back of
your [ __ ] brain and me like that have
a nice conversation and I don't know I
think oh oh I went oh there's nothing
you can't be that help desert whatever
nice guy move about my date
to work out on Sunday or Saturday and I
get to box and burn and Tony lingo Jesus
man what's wrong doing I don't know I
can't really open my I feel yeah I'm
sure you just tired of it yeah that's
what it is or this large cream in copped
in my face and had bird flu well you've
been sick coz I was texting you and I
wasn't getting responses and you were
kind of quiet and the humor wasn't
landing I sent you a picture of a guy
with a mask on and a to Elvis funny
attached to a woman's [ __ ] any party
in his chance because Brian forgot to
post these podcasts you did which I have
a funny story about it if I forget to
post a podcast and if you could just do
me a favor and take your dick put in
your doorway there and then slam the
door for not posting a podcast and be
great
he was I'm sorry here's just good enough
it's guy with like a gas mask on and
it's a tube connected fat girl's ass and
she's farting into the to get stutters
this is high discipline I said oh that
was funny oh my god that was what I
think I haven't too many fart in it and
I'm god no he's over you um it's funny
because I when you're sick like that you
I remember I was at a getting massage
and then I took a shower at a place
called Brooks on Santa Monica and by the
way it was place where if you went to
the sauna you were sure to meet a random
gay guy would just sit there and Doug
was taking a sauna there and the guy
just kept looking at him and Doug goes
bro you got to stop looking at me
because you have to stop staring at me
and they just be sitting there with
their dicks hitting anybody
that's not a soft dick sir you know I
gotta go and their signs no
inappropriate behavior will become they
know something exactly
I didn't rise it was where all the gay
men would go and and suck each other off
in the sauna and I know you got a stuff
you guys stop staring at me man then my
other friend shank said he goes a guy I
was sitting there and another guy looked
and a guy just dobhan the other guy's
[ __ ]
he's like it and the guys going all out
and just like well I'll just sit here
guys let me just ah okay this is a great
daughter thanks guys thanks a lot you
can just suck the random guy's dick and
funny laughter nothing oh yeah - nothing
to see here I'll just count the [ __ ] -
yeah my next little suami dick [ __ ] all
total gaze that happens a son exact nope
nobody's looking
I'll total my thumbs anyway I got 100
degree I got I got a massage and I had a
bad cough and I was like I'd be like you
know you still have fun so a guys
combing his hair blonde blonde probably
about 50 but kind of hit him he had a
necklace for the horn you know like he
was kind of a macho the kind of guy you
look at and you go he's got cologne you
feel sorry for the women in his life
he just looked a little brutal kind of a
mean guy and he's combing his hair thick
hair with up with one of those old
brushes with a handle you not brush but
a comb with a handsome him he's going
like this and I walk by I go that's all
I did hey hey [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
coffee on me [ __ ] it was so
better oh really I was like whoa all I
can do is I go so relax and he goes you
[ __ ] relax [ __ ] [ __ ] him
for any kid who was he ever I skedaddled
I want blossom for human you wanna [ __ ]
no I was like you know you gotta calm
like that you carry a knife on you yeah
I'm out sounds like mafia that's what I
thought sounds like well this guy's game
off here and he might kill me j-mo and
then forced me to dive on his kid let
her drag me in the sauna after I'm a
bloody mess now get on this dick you
[ __ ] and go to coffee I was
telling the story on my on the big round
break down when I was in I was in
Brooklyn I'm you know I'm taking
pictures and signing autographs and
Scalia is [ __ ] shop
hey I'm trying to do a shitty he goes
you [ __ ] leave imma kid I'm listening
to show with my friend I'm with my with
my with my girl Bryan has this [ __ ]
guy I never heard of and my girls
starting to feel all sorry I'm still
sorry guy is [ __ ] friend died two
years ago
we're talking about two [ __ ] years is
what the [ __ ] yours and to top it off
they're dropping [ __ ] and bombs do
you realize this going on when you leave
the drop in [ __ ] and bombs Rocklin
yeah went hold on hold on [ __ ] I start
laughing I go to that what he was yeah I
[ __ ] him Frank wrong man crying friend
pathway two [ __ ] years ago
got this feeling all sad form two years
do [ __ ] is salt it's all fake it's
all fake of it I don't you send me a
text you did somebody do to me cry on
the podcast and drop drop your head bump
amigos and then to make the [ __ ] show
even worse they start dropping [ __ ]
and bomb talk about missing the whole
point
that was like eight and I went why I
said laugh oh it sounds like one helpful
project ideas nah man - [ __ ] in socks
amigos want to take a yourself what just
we there's always somebody harder to
critic no matter what you do there's
always I hope I thought he was hilarious
although I love beg - and he was still
listening we had a we had I I'm hesitant
cellar story but I [ __ ] I want to so
you know hunter moths
tailpiece big brain I have this podcast
mixed mental arts and he has a this guy
Andrew who is a movement coach slash
enthusiast and is a movement kochiya and
Anja's everybody your height and very
good looking kid and he's a buff
spider-man I call buff spider-man and
he's just this big guy who always has a
tank top on always bikes right and it's
always just a movement coach there's a
certain way they dress and act the usual
you are correct sir with the pants home
Connor you referred him is moving coach
as I calm con artist well he's a body
alignment specialist and he came in here
right now I would kick him in the face
so hard as well studio and I know that I
know how you are good guy I'm not good
guy whose color I had something to say
but but but but you know my wife is is
more on more in your camp you know will
the world to my mother sir sir 25 years
of sports and you do the world are doing
this anti-cancer because if you come in
with
Brendan's been doing sports for as long
as he has and had to deal with injuries
and inflammation and all that and you
come in and you say there's an herb that
I have for you I can Brendan's going to
go very cool I don't have time to talk
to you right now because I did sports
where it mattered and I had to make a
living
I've got to get out of here and I
actually love that I love way to do that
but he was he he spends a lot of time
moving when you're talking and sitting
and you know those people who have they
always have their back
ramrod spa does be nuts and their neck
is super high and their chest is super
open could anyone to be very big Paul
yeah he's is good look at it's
uncomfortable it sure is and then he
said like Knights he's sitting in the
sort of in the lotus position
oh [ __ ] you in a chair you know those
guys who said they're big guys he's six
foot five looks like a gargoyle 65 he
looks like a giant got long arms really
muscular and reaches so when if you if I
were to reach for my coffee
just give me my coffee he'll he'll he'll
reach oh man he'll reach and get the
coffee and he's kind of and he'll he's
very aware of everything he does he's a
young man he's a young man who's really
in tune in the body and his loving this
newfound it's a little bit something
he's kind of discovered so it's the
enthusiasm of a cut of a new convert to
a I felt so my he adjusted my
sister-in-law who has bad posture she
has two kids and she's gone so he kind
of helped her out and showed her some
stuff she's like oh wow and then as he's
talking he's he's I make fun of him to
his face this is you know if you know
he's pointing his toes and he's moving
as I'm trying to talk and do this
podcast about body you know we're
talking about basically seeing a salute
yes he was trained did some jujitsu did
some I think he was a basketball player
65 but not at eye level nah the high
school the high school the high school
so high school basketball back right
then Simon did some Jiu Jitsu as you saw
some more title Jiu Jitsu so you tried
no a tie and then attempted jujitsu
price um yeah okay yeah yeah I'm just
trying to I'm trying to cover on my base
definitely not a little bit coach
correct Matt okay definitely on your
level I was well no yeah well no I mean
so so but here's here's the best part
about it and and I am and and again I'm
speaking out of turn cuz he's a [ __ ]
sweet guy and and region his loves life
and is it actually out why you'd love I
may not love him he's a wonderful guy
but set on free but he goes and so he's
moving in my wife is like boy he moves a
lot I mean he's just like this buff he's
Nancy no he's just a he's a buff
spider-man he's always spotless and he's
literally always moving a slight
movement yeah he's just kind of being a
spider my wife well no but but he's
saying saunas and move like them jump on
dick no he's definitely not gay but he
just he just loves to move and my wife
was like alright well he's he's got his
back super straight and I da man is just
being good and at one point she comes
over and I'm distracted auger and she
goes hey I got what spider-man's in the
trade like watch he kind of [ __ ] tree
get him out of the cherry tree I got
outside of he's in a tree is this that
your yeah my home and he's just your
brother yells outside you're out of my
house and he's just up in the tree on
the street and he's just kind of hanging
out the trick and it was uh I got a kick
out of and I was like if Brendan was he
entertaining if Brenda was here he might
pull him from the tree no no no no get
down from the tree like aren't even
you're not a cat I can't I just can't I
just simply can't I know and that's why
I'm telling you that story this is a
woman coaches ladies I'm sure I would
like no you thought of them it's no
sweetheart yeah sweet man and a smart
card but but know what you should set up
a lunch I don't know it's a movement
Cosette for breakfast week of yeah ones
Linux opening and after it up not with
Brendan you can't come up with the old
movement car Ito portal it doesn't
matter Brennan's like mmm Wow cool spent
my whole life moving and I got to be
honest with you Minya camp yeah most be
when you can't and you can't lows be
blood I just think sometimes we're
overthinking things right and like any
companion with Eddie Bronwyn Road
no they should break dance like right
now they should that's exactly what this
should waste their [ __ ] time well
racing well yes kind of memorable all
libras and then how to movement Kermit
some the best moment was Bruce Lee's by
dancing ko who is that yeah it's raising
me and I'm eating stay well it's also
like so there's an industry around
everything right so when my wife was
pregnant
we got talked into having a doula come
to my house now its doula if for those
of you are not in the know in Cal
Southern California a doula is
essentially a birth coach someone who
helps you with you know get ready for
your birth and helps you with exercises
and movement and this woman who I
started laughing you know me because I
get the girl to lose and she was like
baby wants to feel you Moo oh my who and
she I swear to God at one point my wife
and I was sitting there and she got up
put her hands on the wall and began to
move her ass think of a stripper think
of the be [ __ ] a stripper you've ever
met and she was not a bad-looking woman
and my wife was popping and this woman
had I was like you're clearly trying to
bang both of us you have a fetish area
for president women right now I was like
honey using a tea you hit this one out
let me make sure everything's all right
over here if you want that newly paired
train ran over oh she wanted a little
new parent dick yeah and she was just
rubbing her ass in the air like that and
swirling and I looked at my wife I go
you gotta be kidding me right as I said
I started a laughing farmer actually all
that stuff is hilarious like like that
that technical it's not a grand I like
just think it think about like in the
inner city or like when I was growing up
your never tournament did what there's
no movement cooks LeBron James had no
move oh oh it's Chloe bright and have a
boob memory Laura Kay historic but also
like and then think about these these
players you don't have you can barely
afford a babysitter or you know all that
other stuff guys long with kids they
don't have a [ __ ] moms you know
change fake mono help you a movement who
changed my life who changed my back was
a guy named Lauren Landau oh yeah that
that's a guy who's a physical therapist
and spent his whole life studying the
science of physiology exercise
and my other buddy leo leo flowers have
played d1 football now a high-level
trainer and studies and stuff he he was
a real athlete so they they helped me
they literally cured my [ __ ] lower
band a lot with exercise a little bit in
the world yeah I think we got [ __ ]
um I was running yeah I was running
yesterday and I was gone those runs and
I was saying atone chin on chinoe
narsimha what I deal with now everywhere
I go is with the economy Gregory Floyd
Mayweather stuff everyone come on bro
tell you don't [ __ ] believe that man
that there's no good boys gonna kill I
deal with all that all all the time yeah
so yesterday I'm running and this
gentleman who works for a company you
guys would all know I'm stretching like
a gentleman I'm getting done I'm all
sweaty and he's like bro love the
Showtime stuff like oh thanks man and he
goes come on between you and me man I
mean doing a good job acting up there
but uh complete [ __ ] show am i right
like Floyd Sherlock cinema on a Sunday
all right man and I'm like hold on hold
on and I'm engaging in like talking with
them I go :
do you have you watched 40 men with a
fight for you is not a big bond can I go
I go can you name anyone else on a 45
pound division name one other box are
currently 545 107 140 sometimes division
goes no I don't want you that close sale
all right do you watch you have seniors
not a whole lot council viewer I'm like
bro we must vote I'm on us you might as
well tell me a philosophy on [ __ ]
brain surgery guys what are we doing
there I don't know either not I said who
who did you hear that whole Turing from
that you just gave me that you just
rattled out I felt like [ __ ] um
what's-his-name from forget the movie
now remember when I got eat catch again
the Good Will Hunting
right let one gets on me smartly
regurgitates the Harvard but if you just
regurgitate [ __ ] that you read before
and use it as your own yeah I was like
where did my there did you hear that man
where did you hear all this Zucco why
here like not no no no you come up with
your own [ __ ] idea man all you're
going to regurgitate what here
looked into either I think what are we
doing that get alley well you met with
like you spent some time afford I mean
just like Thomas 8 I mean we're on the
tours together you were really impressed
with what a good guy was uh well I was
impressed I shouldn't say good guy known
his you know his background stuff like I
was impressed with the way everything so
calculated and super calculated
everything it runs everything and in
terms of his persona turns out wrong
yeah like he knows exactly what he's
doing
nothing is gonna be comfort but like I
thought there's a chance coming dinner
said I really don't think colors you
know again it's like it he knows exactly
what's going on yeah he's like this is
the only guy I've wanted this my whole
career he's the only guy could do this
with oh is that right he's like easy oh
well it's a show he's having a blast
like all a show yeah it's all shown
though to me it's weird cuz you look at
the mainstream media like today if you
watch whatever show you watch in the
morning there's all this weird
negativity around it and I view it like
this because most people they don't
understand either sport they either know
a little boxing know nothing about do
you see you know a little UFC they don't
know [ __ ] about Floyd Mayweather so
they're come up they're just looking at
these ideas that these mainstream guys
are coming their show opinion on boxing
it's a [ __ ] show that Floyd Mayweather
in Conor turned in it's like that movie
Mean Girls it's the hot new girl sure
and it no one knows them but they hate
on them and everyone else is I got it's
actually kind of cool it's cool
spectacle that you're really interesting
fight there's a lot of cool stories
behind in you have Showtime for should
see if Espinosa overstaying a white
because this is a once in a lifetime
kind of fight we're witnessing sure and
to hate on it's easy because they don't
know [ __ ] about either sport social so
to me it's like the new hot girls I also
loved by you so there's almost a
jealousy yeah they're stuck in their
ways and they don't know no [ __ ] them
have it's actually kind of cool man very
cool is that stomach yeah I noticed that
just as a performer I watched when I
when it looked like me was having a
great time with that the most publicized
faceoff and from all those people and
you were there I think yeah when I
watched it's a little thing but I
watched Floyd as Connor was talking I
watched Floyd he was drinking from a cup
and he raised it in a very ceremonial
way and drank it advocating he was great
even he was already in character
he wasn't even doing anything on the mic
he was already in character and he was
loving it he was healthy I was trying to
explain it tell people how hard it is
when you have four stops so you have you
have LA
Toronto New York London come again you
have to come up with what a half hour
monologues on my [ __ ] every day
oh yeah I mean it's a day yesterday yeah
yeah I mean it is what he was doing this
but also don't name another athlete on
this planet yeah these two I'm telling
you this is [ __ ] and you're waking up
named to her you could do that yeah
you're you're not sleeping you you did
this you follow this my comedy how much
did you in for in my face and I [ __ ]
I don't know what I am exactly you do
have mostly Irish right three hours of
sleep Robbie right now each night right
and then there get up and then you gotta
you gotta be on it man you got to be all
this pressure and not only do they have
always pressures but to perform it uh
when you sit on it the world's watching
yeah I mean writing 15 million views II
yeah oh you better look good and you
better be groomed oh you better be on
the tables critiqued and you better be
on that's right
well I think Solaris is when you don't
make sure me is like yeah it's a bit of
a [ __ ] joke is that you guys only want
to think that she's not very edge kid on
either spore right and you also have
nothing to talk about so this is what
you're doing trying to hate on it man 15
at least 15 million people viewed each
press conference and keep this in my
head why and you did I think a lot of
people are kinda into this yes and you
did a good job of framing it as such
which was this is where the fight begins
in a sense like like don't don't kid
yourself we're waiting to see who can
out sort of talk yeah each guy so that's
not easy to do those guys have got to be
you know witty funny they got a roast
each other that takes she didn't roll a
lot yes and it's gonna be relevant but
the other thing is is and you know I
caught her I got one this press store he
did and he did what we thought he was
going to do the first one is a little
rough but then he learned adapted
exactly it came back and you know kind
of stole the show but to me the mother I
should almost want say the real MVP of
this whole thing is fully mayweather
just because he's forward he's taking
two years off
if we're gonna play tennis you want to
be fun you got to be pretty fun yes so I
went going in and being super biased for
oxycontin still and obviously but at
Floyd at 40 I didn't think you'd be able
to carry his load like I think the icons
can be destroyed and at 40 what Floyd
made I did I like that [ __ ] is in Pratt
I've been doing it forever and you and
you said he's got your close contact
with him everything is calculated
nothing's an accident with that guy huh
nothing like when really tails mother
details really conspiracy theory where
everyone's like he turned off the Mike
Connors Mike he turned out you need to
he was up more upset than anyone he's
got it made to everyone look that oh wow
wow very rare the first kind of got the
Mike in my flame show times in vanozza
mm-hmm Floyd's like I don't what the
[ __ ] that was man so that guy was no
longer there Azusa is the sound guy
right if you got turn on the mic bad and
then they also did the next night with
my boy Brian's Mike who's announcing
guys I know that from reading about
Floyd you know people like say how
talented it was he isn't all that he's
obsessive about his training like
there's no one who trains more than
Freud and ever has like Floyd Mayweather
was like oh yeah he's a genius well he's
also like obsessive about his training
he is he'll wake up at 3:00 in the
morning guy I gotta go running I gotta
train everybody gotta go to the gym so
he's he's he works harder than you don't
work you can't work harder than I know
that's what Freddie Roach was saying
when he was in LA he went to go train at
wild card and he's a cool time companies
like he'll be the round one or two once
we had done with the presser and then we
eat will not be the round one or two in
the morning at about 6 1 or 2 in the
morning he trained all them when and did
it then had stuff the next morning Wow
Sid he's there all night working yeah no
but that did the you know I listen what
he does outside and it's don't ask about
all that I get that terrible but as far
as you want to talk about sewing and
just earning everything they got gods
and hard work yeah that's man yeah
that's not an accident no Springs and
more tonics there's literally the only
two we've ever seen other capable of
doing it I heard Springsteen say one
time he said
nobody is a superstar by accident nobody
in other words if you saw the amount of
work that people put in especially ones
who last as long as someone like Floyd
me yeah for that matter Conor McGregor
you know you he's only been around for
about believe it's huge reps three yeah
but he was talking about how how much
how important media is and people forget
that they're a fighter when you're a
fighter on top of training as much as
you do I thought it was also ensuring
there's a lot of people work hard egos
they think they work hard right I mean
everyone says that the cliche thing like
whenever you see you guys watching the
fights history the Glasgow fights in
Glasgow
they said I was watching Scotland I was
watching those fights and they were
saying you know worked harder than
anyone or is theme a hashtag outwork I'm
like yeah hmm here's the big heavyweight
see those heavy weights under here so a
big big boy did you did you how'd you
feel about the pokey I poked with Gunnar
Nelson I poked wasn't even put wooden oh
yeah Mert ding did I thought yes yep
poked it with a fist to the face in the
press conference he said you know if he
claims that all hell oh poor you know I
remember Jeff Nelson bitten all right
yeah Mert ah interesting
so so overall overall a lot of work but
a blast huh the best yeah we worked in
the same the week of the fight the fight
so to examine are you gonna be at the
fight that's what good deal were
negotiating right now you'll be at the
fight now working that whole week now is
there a shot to bring you I know bro I
know I mean I know no I'm just saying I
know now listen why break ass for seven
Takens got turned down but I'm sure I
can send your resume and see what
happens you know what it did can I be
honest with you I never thought you'd
betray me it's amazing how it is a lose
I will try my beard I forgot about
Albright thanks for the memories
if just call me memories from now on I
kill the old mole memory
old men you met memory lane hey Bry I'll
videotape it on my phone phone phone
I'll FaceTime you
so it's like you're sitting next well
tickets are like I think we're inside
tickets are a million dollars I don't
know the ones they go into the public it
won't be many to the rest like industry
but I think ten thousand you see on your
lap now faced on you man obviously not
although I do my thing see and saying
I'll FaceTime that I'll bring you the
like linear that they give us all right
thanks man your lanyard delay inured
alright that's a little pretty thanks
buddy
oh hey good news bad news bad news is I
can't get you the fight good news is
somebody's bringing you back I had no
land you watch your hat and a nice whoa
whoa thanks I hope you get [ __ ] double
pinkeye in your [ __ ] eyes I can't
give me more PG beads no you look like a
little hamster look a [ __ ] hasty oh
there are hints of grill I an overgrown
hamster oh yeah you know those white
hamsters those albino hamsters a little
out six minutes my brother had a black
cancer with red eyes yeah eight my hands
his face off really yeah hamsters are an
overrated pet oh yeah oh my god the
worst better bullsháá Royals hamsters
I don't hate cuddle them kid oh yeah I
said a trade I said them in the train as
we go around that's about all you can do
is yep I had my son at a birthday party
and my wife knows a people who run
Animal Sanctuary told the surplus
animals you know this is this is
recently yeah I know first birthday I
know I told us what yeah when where
would you say about it I didn't know I
told the story before but this happened
again on Aladdin was oh yeah okay yeah
and you know huge snake tarantula bird
monkey baboon they brought a baboon
brought a baboon reloading no I'm not
brought a baboon now the baboon
considers the the kids in her family who
belonged to the family of the sanctuary
that she's heard their Auntie like so
she's higher up sort of in the baboons
are they do they travel in packs you
know and but the other kids we weren't
the other kids weren't allowed to be
really too close to the baboon because
their teeth are [ __ ] huge and bring a
baboon bottle sharp yep what's the plus
but my wife my wife somehow go
let me do it and the woman said all
right a man is going to pick some bugs
out of and so the baboon my mana walks
up to the baboon
I guess she's hung out with a babbling
before and the baboon looks at my wife
and goes okay and turns her back and
gives her back to my wife and my wife
starts going through her back and
looking for bugs and that's that's
called grooming in the Babylon community
so and she was pretending to eat them
and it was very cute for all the kids
and so the point is my wife speaks
baboon oh and I was I would he ever
relation it with this Batman with the
Fox - I want water breeze I walk about
now now you know what side kids see
alive backbone downside it destroys all
their faces oh the best is their faces
my best is he pulls out a baby alligator
alligator about four feet long five feet
long for Lu yep and two mouths taped
shut and that thing started to piss
I mean ideas of piss piss all over just
all the real hatless they brought all
these animals to your house yeah and the
kids loved it like that yeah not like
animals bro why do you have the scrolls
in there for anything well I was joking
around with my wife and I tried to pick
her up and throw her in the pool getting
around and she goes out there know it I
do that I was like you just whipped my
face up she said it uh sorry don't throw
me in the pool this is that with like
all the kids and stuff yeah I was gonna
throw her I wasn't gonna go job wake her
up I just had a surge of energy you know
I got all roughhouse Sunday on you yeah
I got roughhouse Sunday on her does she
don't play we shouldn't play roughhouse
Sunday she doing on how to play excuse
me while I take these daggers for nails
I have and I'll do I'll stick them in
your [ __ ] grill and in your neck
doing a slit
nothing let's you know you'll let go of
a woman right quick when she's got her
nails about an inch deep in the old
forehead and neck that doesn't feel good
oh did you uh in don't [ __ ] tell me
those fluids okay watch Game of Thrones
but it's not I did not because we didn't
tape the last the first nine minutes of
it so now we have to wait for tonight I
did watch the I just finished season one
you did suggest
season 1 last night I ate it and it's
very good thank you it's very good thank
you how long the season to deny you're
about to get sucked in because almost
sucked in yeah see him to is no joke
why Tex Todd cuz you know after we on
the private jet with the creators of it
I was like add price check it out
thanks God man just finished season one
last night years oh then it should
compare the other seasons just wait I
was like damn right that's better
and because I wasn't sucked in until
then season 2 I was like we got flashed
in for sure her mother a dragon's huh
I'm select to see the mother of dragons
look if you got at that point having the
mother of dragons
o-tama Khaleesi uh-huh well I saw that
it will build up the finale in season
one is her man dice as I did the dime
piece who and she gets the or man tied
to dream you know that is yeah that's
Aquaman yeah that's a he's married to
Lisa Bonet he's the he's Samoan and
admin area yeah he's a big dude he's in
that the she'll come here okay
girlfriend - yeah Jason Momoa Jason
Momoa straight diamond well I've met him
I've actually hung with him a couple
times and been around him and he's he is
he's striking looking like you're like
you're just a [ __ ] giant who'd look
good but he's not that you see 6-3 to 30
okay he looks bigger than that to me
walks I got actors in n63 230 but he's a
dime a dime oh yeah super time oh yeah
yeah really good-looking guy I wanna go
in you know I went to Jody home again
tomorrow in the end of the first season
where I think she comes out of the fire
right now just learning to just part
dragon Chevy right I guess on the ELA
dragging stuff I would um how quickly we
change how about uh quickly the the
language they're speaking when he's
Autobot guys but how how they come up
with all that [ __ ] a lot of what work
how do you remember is he just making
those words up what has to be there they
made up the language but you know like
like [ __ ] that would take too much
time to memorize as an actor and how
about a Muslim Bhagwan Nick I thought
that I was too violent laughable I would
be laughing my glass my ass good what
else what am i doing
Oh what about that guy who a that but it
was the drug like bro you said that
Kentucky like nothing to tell taco are
you saying del Proctor when you try to
know bro and you try to make it a long
language you will start repeating
yourself like I asked you like I have so
much if I was like what I take one with
this bottle with putrefy dude I was
walking around the house doing that and
jozek you got a stop guys I keep saying
the same thing and then I woke my son
son up mother Kelo little annoyed picked
him up kept calm little Lord all morning
and balls deep in game with it gets you
going
Junior are tokine's who wrote the Lord
of the Rings and The Hobbit he created
his legitimately created his own elfin
language yeah I know like an elfin
language super nerd a very smart guy
amazing with that that's a lot more
dated your only and it rosetta stone
hours yeah do your hard that is [ __ ] and
didn't catch on do you guys speak elven
anybody speak lq out here speak out
no because I made it up and I'm the only
one who knows not one but pile equal to
she's I wonder I wonder why he's not a
smash it at the party well we can't
until he's saying he only speaks an elf
but I broke elf
I'll tell you how hard that would be
some with your own alphabet yeah honey
what are you doing I'm writing elfin do
you mind
how long reading Outland the answer is
always ready the answer is always too
long simply too long simply too long is
there anything you do anyway to work on
anything yeah the answers it's like
Daniel day-lewis when he did the boxer
apparently spent three years really
becoming a boxer and I watched the movie
and I was like it's good you're
shadowboxing and I can see that you can
move pretty well but what necessary use
or how about one has he come a comics
cobbler cobbler he made slugs five years
yeah became a shoemaker went to England
mm-hmm
became a cobbler that's I just made
shoes correct sir make sure his works
with leather he's a peculiar fella he's
interesting dude yeah very interesting
guy yeah I'm going to cobble one thing I
want to do always want to do is learn
how to make shoes
finished five years too long yep or I'll
go buy some simply too long discover
when I watch Game of Thrones I always
think about living back then it would
[ __ ] suck well they always say it
sucks so Bob see
any disease you're screwed they get like
in paper coming out and then if you get
infected yeah see you later you [ __ ]
see you later or or personally okay but
you oh yeah
game over oh yeah no heat there's fire
yeah
and then think about everyone had the
bushes just girls bushes and then just
look like [ __ ]
in Game of Thrones - I hate the guys
little bit of like the nice perfect
haircut there's no way now there's no
one person all that [ __ ] they used to
live it up but but bottom lines all your
faves before anesthesia before
anesthesia so if you broke a bone they
gave you a piece of leather bite down on
and they set the bone if they knew how
to do it with your body around no
antibiotics so it has actual right like
they're saying back then our our pain
threshold was higher with anesthesia and
all that our body releases natural
painkillers well now when you're taking
like oxycodone and all that stuff you
guys ago you got this [ __ ] what's
gonna kill it really though if you read
history and if you read novels about
this stuff although you were always
incapable you gotta you got a toothache
and earache in an abscessed and your
breath stunk
and your jaw started to rot that's what
would happen you got pneumonia your
child would die of little things like
that furious smallpox was a great
disease easing deer flu a fever yes sure
influenza killed how many America it's
the thing that uh what's the the small
guy that Peter Dinklage yeah so they're
saying for for him he has it the worst
because I'll see the shows as busy as
possible but he can't go anywhere
because everyone else can look like
disguise themselves all the real things
for yeah Game of Thrones but I'm can't
disguise it so for him he gets it the
worst I've known Peter but up but I was
talking you get you get I'm sure but I
was talking about is you guys have he
like on that show does show Mike sleep
with a girl that I go you gotta go this
wake up they don't brush your teeth they
do nothing
did it have it back now right then
nothing now was he more like so I guess
just humans breath smell like [ __ ] so in
in London and in France they always talk
about and for that matter Italy but
especially through the streets the
upper-class would walk through the
streets with a handkerchief and perfume
and they would walk through and talk
that way because nobody bathed nobody
had access to running water nobody had
access to the gutters the sewers were
open the sewers were used
in a pan I would take your bedpan out
and pour it out into the street that's
why cholera
that's why tetanus all these different
diseases you know which is worth of the
Black Plague people forget the Black
Plague we had three different major
plagues I think in Europe and it killed
off by many historians estimates in the
PDM a third to a half of Europe didn't I
think that the English came up with the
sewer system I changed the game well
different different parts of the world
China had a cent had some the sewer
system they said we shall Roscoe yeah
the system they came up with the
underground not until later but yes yes
yes Europe Europe had amateur games like
that
the English right you know what this is
ridiculous there are turds if you will
yeah they should not disturb ya be
different [ __ ] that's disgusting
and if you see a turd and it's not yours
that a freak yeah if a smart guy season
third he's going we gotta figure
something out you see it turn that's not
yours
hey hold on I'll run I'll run whole
hundred yards Nero's Renison there is a
big difference between a hot snake oil a
piece of [ __ ] yeah and then what listen
to me very carefully and another man's
turn turn a log I will run oh right and
that's where the geniuses in London wit
we can't have turds hanging on the
street you can't understand bleak and I
already number one is get rid of all the
[ __ ] all the turds and and I remember in
New York I was well on my walking toward
a 54th Street to my acting school and
this janitor this black janitor was I
could smell something and he had a hose
and he goes move out of the way watch
out everybody and everybody
instinctively was like that's not normal
and he goes it's humid [ __ ] is what it
is if you're the [ __ ] it is like a
hazardous waste area you know they did a
thing of worse smells in the world and
human shits number one I believe that
number one I believe that I remember I
remember and pick up my socks in our
library I think I was in fourth grade
you ever want a kid would be like sick
and it's throw up and then that poor
Janet come in put like that pink
weird like yeah product down ahead like
hello chips and pink [ __ ] all you like
porn on the ground then we're just
supposed to keep on learning like that
never had
but it doesn't like [ __ ] like that just
cleaned everything up and wear that
stuff why were some kid took a [ __ ]
some kids ship it and it was on the
floor generators I don't know how I
wants to do they just take that same
pink stuff he tries to clean up the [ __ ]
and they dump it over the [ __ ] and I'm
learning about [ __ ] fish and snakes
and [ __ ] in biology or whatever the [ __ ]
goes in and it just sounds like complete
[ __ ] well you know he goes we lose the
teacher she goes well that we don't have
any like so penny goes we want me do we
use this for everything what do you want
me to do him and leave you know they get
rid of a terrible terrible thing to
think about but how to get of like the
blood on highways when somebody dies
like that terrible accident believe us
let's tough to get out yeah I know what
they do if you remember like weird so so
so if there's somebody gets hit by a car
somebody gets shot somebody gets you
know the guy who comes along but
especially somebody gets really [ __ ]
up Lee Highway
kitty litter they drop kitty litter down
all you only see today like yeah they
drop kitty litter diets so cause it all
sorbs it absorbs it because only like by
watch way too much murder shows but that
the blood it's only thinking oily like
even when you're fighting if you blend
your eye like an you keep like like as
soon as a drop getting eye it's like
this weird like like your seal in the
oil spill the ocean like the film it
just it doesn't go can't really see
through that it's like no no no it's so
filled with oil so I get to cut on his
head massage you're dangerous here you
can't and and there's a lot of other
dangers but one that you can't see you
can't see at all yeah I'm sorry that
when the blood so sick you can't see
anything
damn is so this soil into what do you do
in a fight like that you just kind of
deal I guess with the idea that you can
take out but you got to hope that it's
either random the side that's going to
end it yet problem yeah Wow
but yeah blood like on those murder
shows when they when they show it's like
men the time they must expect
clean this murder up because if they
let's say they got to shoot him with an
axe like whatever 30 times
there's blood [ __ ] everywhere so
whoever did it say it's one or two guys
threw up all night cleaning because it's
so tough to get away huh so now now what
they have you're so screwed if you're a
murder and you
now they use like whatever bleach or
something or whatever you wanted to get
have a spray that shows it's right where
the blood was about that
so the Mafia that this guy was talking
about he had a wig on you know they had
like a guy and he said got a wig eyes
witness protection
shitty sunglasses and a hat you know
iron and he's like you know for us to
say was it in part of the game you know
a crime that man they just kill people
is take the body gang up you believe it
got always bleed it first then you cut
it up then what we do is we cut it up in
pieces take it out on a boat just drop
it off for the fish or you put it in a
car and when the car gets smashed
you know the tailor's junk your ass now
you're in a under you know you know 27
tons of metal nobody's gonna [ __ ]
find you yeah I didn't do it yeah but
you got to bleed it otherwise the walls
will be others so I'll find its way out
trees - way out yeah it's an important
thing to know when you kill somebody
everybody I do piss so hard hopefully we
won't tell anyone on the way
you got a pee yeah let's go piss on okay
me help you out please
you know dive on my [ __ ] like the guy
name is autumn I'm gonna shake you out
shall we go to some current events let's
jump on some currents jump on in jump on
it is in current of BAM alright the
first card event is obviously a sad one
and creepy oh oh he's is chin yeah cuz
you want to start off and then make it
happy in the okay but so skydiver sent a
video to his wife a really quick video
message saying I'm gonna not pull the
cord when I jump out of the plane like
just moments before he jumped out and
she found out she ran up to the hangar
station and had them called a plane and
it was already too late the guy had
jumped out and so he committed suicide
and then he wrote in the message he's
not going to pull the cord and that he
was going to go somewhere wonderful it
was he mentally ill or what there's no
like there's nothing as pastor showed
that and plus he had like 600 skydives
before so that the way in is that symbol
of know a happy affairs like that he's
making a choice yeah he I think it 600
jumps or something like that
600 but did he have mental illness
what's going on here depression about
nothing about mental illness
I think some people have been thinking
about it for so long and they finally go
you know what I'm done if you hear like
a lot of like ah I've only read a little
bit about suicide I don't know anything
else but I do know that people who come
into is that a lot of times have been
thinking about it for a long time and a
lot of times they try it a lot before it
actually happens so a lot of times they
they tell people people commit suicide
like the real gamers they don't tell me
down time people who tell someone
they're looking for a way out
they're looking for help they want you
to get them out of it yeah this whole
boy was like [ __ ] and see yeah pretty
gangster yeah pretty terrible way to go
I don't know I guess or I think it worth
it or it's very quick and sudden God
like in games of Game of Thrones right
he gets his head cut off I thought that
would be a good with yeah you're done
quick game over right away this is it
like this dude I was like god I don't
know I think you probably scared and
ahead and just we've just done your head
you know you know what they find in
plane crashes right that when when a
plane crashes my friend's brother friend
Johnny's brother used to be the one who
inspected the site and you would find
people's shoes in the front of their
shoes were blown out and you'd find
bones and the in the shoe because your
body goes through your shoes your body
literally the force of the impact your
body will go through your shoes like you
soon
flights would then call out your blowout
that's called that's called a serious
blow I love the blow yeah I guess asses
yeah the blowout that's right you're
hitting that hard or you're Sheldon just
leaves the meet yep leaves the meet
vehicle that's right Shelton's just
kidding that's it so you're just left
with a would meet that makes sense what
a meet least and meet vehicle cuz
somebody said that when they shoot this
guy was saying when they put a goat in a
tank and they're they're practicing to
see what a weapon what a bullet does
like certain like anti-tank you know
personnel giving these goats can easily
see what happens to organic material
inside the thing they say big be the
it'll go through the hull of the tank
and then I guess out the other side and
the force it's so strong that it shoots
the goat out of
hold the size of a quarter is weird I
was like let's shoot yeah I don't get
what you mean I guess the pressure in
the tank so when the bullet goes in it
disintegrates you know everything in
there but the force of it pulls the goat
out the other side so you kind of blow
out the other side yeah yeah
crazy you feel anything I guess you
don't I guess you know very good like
one time or you liquefy because the heat
is so intense so quickly just judge like
that that's what you want those I guess
I don't feel like dying in a tank but
you know I won't say if you're gonna go
that's what you were probably quick like
you want to see we don't feel anything
yeah you want to get shot in the hip and
die this as bad as the entire time we've
fallen you have like did he did - was he
like on I don't want it dying well he
could sue the court if you wanted to say
event I found this do it if ventually
found him facedown in an open field near
the runway all right yeah well except
you have kids I don't know about kids
that might be the happiest looking
person I've seen her on that plane that
we doped up like Jesus Christ he looks
happy
okay was happy skinny or was happy yeah
there you go over the Frog on Felix
happy earnest damn oh what a bummer
yeah all right
well that's what he wanted though you
know you did huh
unfortunately but okay so mommy I don't
see why more old people don't do that
you know when they like wanna like the
dr. Kevorkian redhead people die don't
talk to cavort you like listen here's
the easy way to do it yeah just jump out
a plane illiteracy I had a family
remember all that wow that's terrifying
no I had a family terrifying who is 90
the job done
Eddie founder is 90 I told you about and
he shot himself he's 90 he was 90 got
his car wrote a note and drove a little
bit farthest it wasn't too much of a
mass shot himself in his car with a note
he was an old you know military guy but
he was done and he put everything in
order now put everything in order he was
in pain put everything in order you know
and and wrote a letters and everything
else and set it all up in his will and
then just gotten a card going and I told
most of my guy friends that and they
were all like that's [ __ ] gangster man
he was
he was a John see ya you know so
everybody goes out on their own terms
you know or not on their own terms but
if you can some people choose to it
depends what kind of 90 were talking if
you'd like I know sometimes yields who
are healthy just doing the damn thing
then I think he was very lonely and not
connected to all his wife died as
grandkids meeting yeah yeah do what you
want to do women there you go so little
[ __ ] alright the next one is a vegan
activist activists family they walked up
to this family fishing and they told
them that they just caught a fish a
tilapia and they left it on the ground
and they told them that it was like what
did they have yeah they have feelings
they feel pain you can't be doing this
and it was like to stand out for a while
and then the guy that was the dad okay
so a little kid walked up to his family
it was the son of the activist and he's
like sir sir the fish feels pain you
know just being like even kid be like
kid let it go yeah yeah and the guy
lookin said brainwash their son the
thing about putting all he long limbs
you keep going but no baby pretty much
did bring watch their son if you watch
the videos too long to show but the kid
is like all about him what his parents
are saying and they're chanting lines
about like a you know fishing is
violence or something like that Maddox
phonetics by the way just so you know
plants have been shown to react to very
loud music in an adverse way things like
that in fact even being cut so there's a
lot of evidence that plants behave the
way animals do but in a very slow
process you can know make noise so you
could also make that you can make the
point that maybe you're also hurting
plants too and the fact is life eats
life I like my animal protein I think
people like this are obviously fanatics
and the kid's gonna grow me they're
gonna Bobby's gonna be nice to me all
you gotta really and listen thanks a lot
on to what evening yes so many friends
in school at the lunch table when
everyone's eating chicken nuggets and
you got a [ __ ] tofu bar yeah you're
gonna turn out just fine my man eat that
soy and see how that works out where
your Crocs were those man capris a nice
tank top and a beanie halfway back and
be skinny is fun the exception of Jake
Shields and he's not even
vegan he t2 eggs and cheese and
everything else but the most part I
haven't seen too many muscular healthy
athletic vegans I know they're out there
relax everybody I'm sure there are three
or four examples that you'll send me and
I know like go [ __ ] yourself
and all due respect to vegans I have no
problem with it but it's just not good
when you lose your wisdom on other
especially fishing PETA PETA PETA
my friend runs the sanctuary and and he
does trans animals for movies and PETA
wants no animals and movies matter what
no animals and I think that that you
know animals and movies if they're
treated the right way and I know that a
lot of people say people there's no such
thing but animals and movies are the
treat of the right way the way my dog is
treated or whatever they educate people
and they show people to love animals and
respect animals in fact so again be
careful of fanatics and also watching
Ludd okay what's your bud and tell me
that the dog wasn't treated exactly I've
been on set with all those animals and
they're treated better than humans
usually so go [ __ ] yourself although
there I put back is another example for
you animal activists watch Dunston
checks in and then complain to our faith
yeah come on complaining watch Dunston
checks and tell me he's not a grand old
time at those whales okay go [ __ ]
yourself although I do think that
keeping dolphins and really smart
animals and big pools is [ __ ] up when
I were I had a lot of fun out there
there's a dolphin this Ventura pet
detective he had a grand old time he had
a wonderful time they're always smiling
and they're jumping around you can ride
them and you can ride them and that
Steve Byrne always says you're never
you're never more gay than when you're
riding a dolphin what else you had to
wait so they actually grabbed their fish
and threw in the water like if you guys
are fishing and caught a fish my
property you thought line up and yeah
take your fish well I say this for these
animal nuts you know the oil from our
fingers when you grab a fish actually so
when you you think you're helping you
know people catch and release and when
are the oil from our skin all that when
you grab the fish's body you toss them
back in they typically die anyways you
know that ah yes I did yeah so when you
grab the fish like you shouldn't be
touching at all if you want to live
don't be but I'm going to get the
they usually diet exactly but also
they're not very smart other these vegan
these guys were trying to save fishermen
there are other things to do right there
are a lot of problems in the world if
you're running around trying to save
fish and Families trying to catch a
tilapia which by the way is a shitty
fish they used to use tilapia for a fish
meal hey hey y'all fish loves matter man
sorry brought a lot with is a swordfish
yeah together sorry Pig and all but also
these [ __ ] activists come up this way
how dare you kick like you think [ __ ]
Michael Vick in that fish in that Lake
was good for him I think yeah you think
he landed everything was all good right
right now and the fish out there for a
long time already thing up in the orange
roughy that you used to see on menus a
lot though
they found that aren't released live
like literally 200 years oh I've got a
75 year old orange roughy it's a
teenager he hung its young they were
like hey careful you get these orange
roughy and it's like if I would have a
little bit of an issue killing something
that was gonna live 240 years yeah like
I don't want tortoise jerky no I would
go your tortoise yeah you got a long way
to live don't give me an elephant fillet
right well I'm gonna cut down this old
growth Twitter's been standing for 600
years wait a minute I don't want to be
the one who does that yeah with you yeah
with us kitchen all right how about this
Ann Coulter did you see her tweets about
Delta L I have not quite feel like she's
not very smart she's very smart actually
but it's kind of like the way she comes
off on TV I'm just like God she seems
like she's out to lunch all the time
she's a bit what were her texts she has
a whole bunch of stuff that she tweeted
against Delta because they moved her
seat she had her she had her she had her
ticket right and she spent the time to
get the seat she wanted because she's
tall he's got long legs right house
although I don't know but she's pretty
sick yeah succeed succeed long legs no
smaller she but she wanted her own seat
and she was sitting in her seat that she
paid extra for Delta comes along does
you have to get out of the seat she goes
watch because well we don't know so
instead of and they moved they moved her
right over to the other seat but it
wasn't the seats you pay for because it
was it was a little more cramped
okay here's the problem don't flame it
was somebody old patient rise by that
and a wedding on Air Force One it wasn't
somebody was old it wasn't somebody
who's handicapped that wasn't a child
it was a regular woman and then she
tweeted out was kind of funny right
there I was like this regular woman
don't give my extra extra room seat to
an Air Marshal at all person here's a
woman
given my pre-booked seat then hehe she
called her she goes and you give a woman
you give a woman with dachshund legs my
seat dachshund legs meaning you know a
dog small dog absolutely draw dots on my
browser with a mean looked somehow I'll
browse are my bra browsers pissed
they're all pictures that she's taking a
picture of him so they're in within the
loon on first client he exited that
emergency bro I believe that's the
emergency room and the girls is yes
she's made her name by being super
offensive and in this case you know and
then Delta tweeted her back we're sorry
the reflection $30 she goes additionally
your insults about our other customers
employers are unacceptable and
unnecessary she goes $30 cost me 10
grand on my time to pre-select the seat
I want an investigate type of plan and
go back periodically to review seat
options I've been the picture of
politeness if I treated customers the
way Delta does I deem facts imply - but
here's what I thought was funny hold on
today's customer quiz why is delta worse
than united a united drags customers off
the plane but soon delta will have to
drag them on that's all it was so she
won she keeps your credibility I thought
it's funny that's hilarious
I bet the idea at Delta corporate office
loves having social justice warriors
running their customer base I look
hilarious I'll be follows a chef a lot
at least in 1.3 million or something 1.6
Jesus Chris I bet her books all right
Jesus she's not very fair I don't agree
with her a lot but I've read her books
look slave that's a good tweet though oh
yeah
when a woman of her stature was she
doing up flying for his class ah is that
not first class no no I there are those
that me why does this select now but
she's going from a lot of wishes you
learn from I think Ella did New York
no yes LA to Florida or something like
that yeah it's a long place so long
flight and also that tickets about 1700
bucks so she was like like me she's like
[ __ ] that I'll depend to 400 bucks and
get extra legroom
I'll suffer for five hour to death we
say we don't mind
that's actually the lira see little bits
not but also dealt like let's not let
dump up the hook here whether you like
her naughty support or not he does that
would suck I wouldn't be really mad I'd
be upset what I you're not allowed to
miss tilly just tweeted yesterday United
[ __ ] you know this is you know I've lost
my [ __ ] on people on airlines all the
time I get really mad about it man we're
going to force on a first-class seat
with with American I flew mint on
JetBlue I may as well had my own it was
like a condo I my own condo somebody
came in there gave me a stake in a
dicksuck the whole thing was amazing I
get out like an American I spend the
same amount of money it was it so
literally
yeah what a plane [ __ ] seat I was
like this is an essential regulation the
same should I get on coach on something
uh you know virgin yep I lost my view an
older plane with Delta or that's I never
flying American or Delta's yeah does it
play there's a chance when you the old
old place that's right and your big boy
your big boy you get I've sat with you
coach it's all cramped up rough life
yeah you got them shoulders struggles
real you got them long leg look I got a
tally of dog time to do television for
that what else kitchen alright so Reebok
they put out this tweet I think it's a
tweet about the the way Donald Trump
acted in front of the French president's
first lady because he when he met her
he's like oh you you look a huge and
shelfie yeah you look healthy yeah
beautiful
so Reeboks for some reason sent out this
tweet like a I don't know what what
should be appropriate for that kind of
conversation and there's a bunch of
different scenarios that they put here I
don't know why Reebok did this either
because they're part of this social
justice issue so so here's they mean
attention yeah they need some sort of a
yellow also I love how everybody now
Reebok this is a corporation and and we
this is what happens with the social
justice worship what happens is all of a
sudden we are being told what's
appropriate to say and what's not
appropriate to say including when you
get somebody a compliment apparently has
that's one the shape
sexual harassment what's wrong with you
you can get sued now but why does Reebok
trying to educated Reebok knees spend
way more time on designing shoes and
t-shirts yeah are you and I next to a
woman ordering your morning coffee
you're not allowed to say that are you
at the gym working out next to a woman
you're not allowed to say that you're in
such good shape beautiful I can't I
can't give a woman a compliment like
that you guys are telling me all you
guys are telling me how I can speak to
another human being this is what
happened this is tyrannical because now
I'm considered what I'm sexually
harassing her I'm considered a male
chauvinist pig considered a bully I'm
considered a predator all this [ __ ]
this is what happens everybody when you
allow people like this to dictate how we
speak they put all the HIPAA our online
laser hungry tone because Reebok is part
of this social justice with the river
will not be shouldn't but this the first
like evil because the people running the
show the people in human resources etc
the people at this is what's going on
this is this is what's going on and and
so everything you say is considered very
very offensive apparently that's
offender well the way I would do it is
however wise this would be the last on
my mind for them right they have so many
more fun no [ __ ] but think about this it
speaks to a much bigger issue they're
trying to control how you speak so Jim
Norton feels the same way you do you
guys do any wrote this tweet Thank You
Reebok for your virtuous message about
when it's appropriate to compliment a
woman shape and then he actually posted
a picture of Reeboks ad of a girl with
her butt showing that's wholly about
their toning she's awesome live awesome
way to go Jen love Jim yes let's
collision yes speaking sense
[ __ ] you Reebok and [ __ ] you with all
your dumb social justice word and [ __ ]
you with your tyrannical idea of how I
should speak and compliment a woman [ __ ]
you this puts you over tough you haven't
rather the fighters know it's all
bothersome man it's much bigger issue
we're dealing with men you know you can
lose your job for saying something the
wrong way ignoring why are you with us
good fight back everybody fight back for
sense upon rested and children placement
character Tony a million see myself in
wagon hey it's real excited about
I did bro those I worried about the the
listeners they're like what's going on I
know me Touhou a mom was arrested for
towing her kids with their little wagon
tied to her car on a sweat on an actual
street and she literally thinks there's
nothing wrong with it it was fun for the
kids and you can see there on actual
pump oh my god
she has no idea why some people just out
here just so daughter they're so dumb
she loves her kids I'm sure but you
you're not drunk that's not smart
oh man human sources have placed the
children care of another person I don't
know if that's fair oh they'll do you
take her children from her when she was
just trying to she loved how Jesus so
dumb like that so so [ __ ] dumb that
maybe his proprio can take her to the
river but you're saying she's you gotta
go you got it we got to get put you in
some classes now this is where we boxers
come in and say all right here's right
here's your five here's your here's your
project coming senator [ __ ] in this
smile I will fight kids and got some
shoes and then some pamphlets on just
how the world way her pay for her
college solid parenting college pay for
the fifth sixth grade Wow college that's
your fight Reebok that's your fight
[ __ ] what your aim towards that
[ __ ] Reebok man that's a bummer it's
just a bummer all the way around because
kids at beauties again we're not we all
don't start the same starting line man
yeah it's just a bummer you are correct
don't take her kids though that's [ __ ]
up obviously she's learned she's like oh
my god what the hell was I thinking
hopefully yeah I hope hope so
so yeah I fine I'll do it from the back
of motorcycle I said little suggestion
all right Google released 20 million or
they're going to be releasing 20 million
mosquitoes that they created from a lab
with the bacteria to infect the Zika
carrying viruses mosquitoes they damn
amazing thing and then I drew Fresno the
other alpha mosquitos kill the other one
they're doing an amazing right ladies
all Zika mosquitoes stung me in both
eyes
yep well they're doing a great job of
this because they in Tahiti that a pilot
Pro
and where there are no mosquitoes and
what they do is they I guess they
release a bunch of mosquitoes that
render the other mosquitoes I think they
give them a virus where they become
sterile and these violin these are
sterile as well and so basically all
that they stop breeding they can't make
anybody lay they all die it's really
really effective and the male mosquitoes
they don't bite us so yeah it's when
just the females but yeah yeah they're
there they're um they're getting rid of
mosquitoes worldwide pretty cool
and they've and even like people have
looked at what their role is nikkah
system and stuff I guess we could afford
to get rid of mosquitoes when we
probably because malaria kills I think
more people in any disease we hurry to
kill more people
anything yeah most disabled of all kind
yes you know that Oh can't take it
serious it is your little got me in the
eye yep your eyes are pinkish [ __ ] there
kubera yeah a giant hamster all right
keep going to history still have red
eyes they do I don't know much about
this one but an Australian Center who
he's been there for nine years found out
that he's actually from New Zealand so
he was eyeing
okay all the respected is notice doing
who gives a [ __ ] it's a living link it's
not valid that rule I hate it I know
but I mean come on guys what is that
sort old he's like what all right I've
been touched all [ __ ] about New Zealand
unless you're from this I mean he they
moved when he was three so apparently
now you're not allowed to write this
hilarious though about that news when we
found Isaac I guess I'll leave it was
things yeah I got no big deal I missed
you ever so funny it shouldn't be
because you know the message to is three
so everybody calm down
yeah you come on man you okay relax it
was only different that's hilarious -
what else yet hey what you say it
between announces regulated everyone I'm
sorry about this but it's a thing there
are other ways to make trouble
love and things everyone it's a thing
till I can use this Muse your waves
where's your wave travel love I'm your
love in taxes hey it's a thing I like
how its general Todd like that if I ever
get caught doing something really bad
hey everybody sorry
it's a 3-2 thing otherwise make trouble
man
love and laughs love lights and banks
live love is life without sex per se
anytime you're told it's a thing trying
to run live love and life and with the
guys uh everybody's explained sorry but
it's a thing all right well there are
other ways to get off this was a loving
dick it's all I'm going to say from
knows what can you do it to things love
Dickson tank love live laughs thank you
everything is everything is there
anything love live laughs anything lots
of porn where the guy was like just he
and his buddy when there's other guy in
there this really hot girl and they just
gone to town he's like he's he's kind of
easing anything he's gone everything's
everything what everything is just
everything
what sir you're white the teleportal are
you watching um I remember I was joking
up to ferocious grace everything was
blurry but you read my head it returned
say it again everything is everything
the white dude no but I said that just
for the joke okay one night you were so
like a [ __ ] whack out why cry
[ __ ] well weird everything is
everything she was from my Eastern
Europe I appreciated it didn't believe
she could take all of that down sorry
everybody
private private conversations okay a
British woman found out that she was
wearing 27 contact lenses in one of her
eyes Oh for years and years and years oh
well she should get together with a girl
who's tracking her kids in the that's
all he does Hey humorous conduct if you
were God I have you a I reach in no I'm
bored I was connect for many many of you
said
Sergio mais OU and he let me tell you
something you would definitely
definitely know anyone that's wearing
contacts listen this right now is like
what [ __ ] 27 cots
then it's a lean piece of basically
plastic on your eyeball how does 27 fit
in there I mean what kind of mother took
a ten contacts create a total of 27
contacts in one eye
what what are you
me a one time when I was playing
lacrosse you're playing Fort Collins I
was wearing contacts and it got so cold
out that my contact basically froze I
was like waiting for the ball to hit me
in my contract the Shatford in my eye
really oh my god my god I was so cold I
was just like zoning out in my contact
froze and so heavily these dudes Wow Wow
picture of this dummy I mean this woman
they don't show it this is another guy
oh wow how many did he have no he had
something else it stitches for improper
contact lens in is so weird that kind
but she was 67 Oh
so I mean later people have been all
there she wasn't taking him out she was
adding a blue mass of 17 contacts all
stuck together later doctors found
another chunk of Ted contacts we were
told of 27 none of us have ever seen
this before no [ __ ] it was such a large
mass all sending contact lenses were
stuck together we really surprised that
a patient that knows that because
because quite a lot of irritation while
sitting there yeah no [ __ ] that's so
nuts
after I removed the lenses she said her
eyes felt a lot more comfortable I want
to surprise God that would hurt I get my
eyes are watering and I know I look like
[ __ ] on my eyes or water just thinking
about that yeah your head contest when
doctors have all kinds of stories like
that weird stuff they find people stuff
shoved up their asses all the time and
in their stomachs yeah it's like them
like spray paint cans from the area
gerbils yeah light bulbs yeah eggs yeah
yeah crowbars you know let's see what we
can put in there they get high he is
high shouldn't like let's put that in
there or like my friend of my helpers me
a picture of a guy he was over one guy's
shoulder hit him over his shoulders a
big guy he killed him all our yup and he
had his fist and he was just he was
giving him the old fist arou with a lot
of soap around but a foam it was very
attractive oh I know because well 15
assisting yeah yeah some people like a
lot of stuff in there but he is yeah
lost and fit a lot of stuff in you don't
it you can see but it drugs up there yep
you can put a lot of shoulders you can
put directly to mix
drugs ever digs drugs fists fists shoe
so you can find any of it eight
you can find almost anything in your ass
on the internet I mean you know people
put crazy people put hamsters and
gerbils up for failure
please nibble up there yep yep they
duct-tape them so they move around a lot
so we don't mean it well yeah I mean now
I understand a gerbil
now how do vegans feel about it well
there I like everybody
a vegans if you want a guy to kind of
hide and I'll be like your muscle if we
find out like there's a house that's
using durable to shove up human asses
yeah I'm down to kind of like let's
break down the door durable yeah let's
break down that because that if you made
dick a spot on the wall sir open your
ass I got a check something
hopped on some lettuce and your
underwear all right I know it's going
talk about some risk takers to take a
gerbil and shove it up yes in hopes that
he comes back down so weird so weird I'm
sure it's a little feeder explain your
thing about that do they sanitize and
feet micro-tears everywhere no if I clip
the nails got a clip his nails look even
it's pink balls it's stepping feces wow
you clean I guess that's the old job you
clean the box don't be smelling up the
poop by [ __ ] your [ __ ] is no big
deal yeah that's good point pretty dirty
rat so I should handle yeah yeah yeah
it's not that clean I have a friend who
was dealing with a lot in and out of
rehab and he's on the run now but
they're not even makes complete sense he
used to take shots of Jack Daniels in
his ass oh yeah yeah people do say I
want to get more drunk coffee enemas put
things in your ass all you put the
coffee on you'll do a caffeine you
absorb the caffeine somehow that's what
suppositories are you got all that and
get you into that with drugs too right
oh yeah people do with Molly and stick
them right after cocaine is real cooking
right in the rump or rump right right
they're very dangerous I would imagine
if I pass it isn't go straight to your
questions like when you take it it you
just filter to your liver Oh wine and
all this I don't know but when you're
straight up there goes riding with a
blood straight at the poker what would
you do then take a straw and blow the
cocaine in your [ __ ]
typically what a gentleman would do is
have a nice attractive young girl take a
straw enter it into your anus
okay full of the devil's dandruff
then blood straining your poop chute huh
losing the blockage and then guess what
he partying he partying all night when
she looked at [ __ ]
I died she's willing to blow Coquina up
there now yeah yeah sky's the limit
guys what's left after that not much not
much to devil me I that's right
thank guy okay good way to get pink at
it really is now you guys know how your
pink that's right little Doody flies
little microscopic duty flies nearby
ball
don't call dump call to me go to your
doctor get some antibiotic pinkeye
abside everybody how about this Michael
Irvin says he wants an MMA fight any
serious
I love Michael I really do that though
he said he wouldn't he will obviously
not do like the big leagues but he wants
to do a celebrity type I don't you like
to yeah fighters well even the best goes
for you I love Michael urban though he's
love I love Michael Irvin um well that's
that guys did I saw the funniest thing
you know JLo I just remind Mary they see
JLo and a ride there there's a picture
of JLo on Instagram and she's like she's
her and I love her and a rod the vlm
season a rides uh like closet and she's
out you know show states she
ridiculously gorgeous look at forty
fifty or someone at forty eight and
she's like this and sure trucks like
she's right in great shape and somebody
god damnit jail been with a rod for less
than a month that she's already on peds
she's like so funny so true yep good
company like guns couple oh that's it
Jim that's it buh-buh-buh-buh-buh ah a
quick dropping knowledge I aren't saying
interesting an interesting concept which
was you as a human being could have two
contradictory thoughts in your head and
it's okay so sometimes you can have two
virtuous thoughts in your head so when
you're trying to deal with a problem you
might be caught with the idea of justice
and mercy take Sam Harris was talking
about the zones podcast take immigration
take the Syrian problem and you have a
country that is overrun with your with
this influx of refugees the humane thing
to do of course is to give these
children
people are desperate need food water and
shelter it gets to a point though where
you can't it gets to a point where the
right thing to do is in fact just for
your own survival or your own the order
of your own society whatever is to
actually not allow it to happen and
that's a very difficult place to be you
can think about it you make those
decisions with yourself all the time
borders are reasonable and we all have
borders for ourselves and everything
else and I think as you get older you
realize that life is [ __ ] complicated
and there are times when you have to
make a choice between two goods you have
to make a choice what's what's better at
that moment so is justice better at that
moment or is mercy better at that moment
I don't know it depends on the situation
but it points largely also to
understanding that as a human being man
you're always in flux you know that it'd
be be nice to yourself and be nice to
other people and sometimes when you make
decisions it's very complicated and
something is gained and something is
lost and that's the way it is and when
you're an idealist when you when you
when you stick to an ideology when
you're like no there's only one right
way in one wrong way all immigration is
bad let's build a wall or whatever the
opposite let words come down everybody
in no man no no that's not the answer
it's usually somewhere in the middle be
be a thinker and and realize that the
answer sometimes is in the gray and
sometimes the dancer changes according
to how the world moves and changes with
it so that's what I have to say be more
compassionate the answers are
complicated they're not anybody it says
there's right way the wrong way
sometimes there is other times there
isn't a lot of times there's more
complicated right being right man
speaking of right and wrong which and
they fun you know this week Brendan I am
so glad you got out of you I can't be
gonna be any more right when you go see
brother he'll think you're right brother
and you know what I'm gonna be at the
right your head you're almost like being
okay I need you oh you're pink I was
getting that off I want to be at the
comedy zone in North Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina this Thursday Friday
Saturday the 20th 21st 22nd get your
freakin tickets at t that you know
teaches us the energy connect your place
okay or tickets are talking ever you 2d
cuter now your teeny Brian gallon bottle
see me get your ticket okay defecate
Kong defecate Oh calm not the Canberra
something uh yeah and you can get their
DG's I'll be in Phoenix
this Thursday I'm at Salt Lake at wise
guys on Friday could close shows have
less than 20 tickets go right now T back
a.com Voltas [ __ ] should sell out go
right now
Phoenix this Thursday Friday is Salt
Lake City and the next week I am in
Toronto which is sold out in Chicago and
Detroit there tickets left at Chicago
Detroit might be sold out and then I'm
off to Dublin in London where all those
tickets are sold out boom tik calm
Phoenix Salt Lake get them right now
I will see you this week get to DG kiss
and I'll be enough by the way Montreal
Kappa Cleopatra 24th to the 30th I'm
doing I'm headlining those shows come on
by
boom this is a fighter kid we're out